more at this altitude I can run flat out
for a half-mile before my hands start
shaking gloriously perfectly now it is
the type of netic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
the episode is brought to you by Vera
desk and are actually standing at my own
Vera desk right now recording this
you've probably heard of research that
shows how sitting all day is terrible
for your health sitting is the new
smoking etc but standing all day isn't
necessarily the answer for everyone
sometimes you just want to sit down and
that's true for me as well the middle
ground is Vera desk Vera desk height
adjustable standing desk solutions allow
you to stand when you want to and sit
when you need to and as an example I
have this set to the lower position this
is a large model and it took me clickety
clack two seconds to raise this thing up
and it feels like has hydraulics
effectively because I didn't have to use
any muscle to do it Vera desk converts
your existing desk for instance if you
want to get a tabletop version which you
can put on which is very very cool or
cubical into a sit stand workstation and
allows you to raise your desk from a
seated to standing position in just
seconds
ships fully assembled so there's no
Allen wrenches screwdrivers required
pull it out of the box put it on your
desk in the case of this particular
model no installation or fastening
required there a bunch of different
options models start at just 175 dollars
so check out Vera desk comm to see what
model might be the right fit for you and
my assistant now has one I have one
we've really really been very happy with
it so if you're not sure if it's right
for you that's fine they have a 30-day
risk free guarantee which once you try
it in your own home or office and if you
decide it's still not for you you want
to get rid of it they arrange to pick it
up no hassle so check it out Vera desk
calm that's var I desk calm
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high end financial advice that the
best private wealth managers deliver to
the ultra wealthy but for any account
size and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers from
the software wealthfront now manages
more than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront
is powered by innovative technology
making it the most tax efficient
low-cost hassle-free way to invest they
don't have bloated sales teams or retail
locations so they can deliver all of
this sophisticated financial advice and
these services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor so
the very least go-to wealthfront comm
forward-slash Tim and take their free
risk assessment survey it only takes a
couple of minutes and wealthfront will
recommend a personalized portfolio of
investments in other words they'll tell
you exactly where they would put your
money so even if you don't use their
service you have a huge leg up and you
have additional information for making
good decisions they use investment
theory to automate good financial
behavior and decisions that people
typically don't make but should so go to
well front comm forward slash Tim to get
your first 15k managed for free or just
to get more details check it out well
front comm forward slash tip
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is my job to dig
around find world-class performers of
all sorts of stripes and breeds and
species and deconstruct what they do how
do they make decisions what do they do
first thing in the morning what are the
habits routines details that you can
apply to your life and this particular
episode was very much an in-demand
requested episode and the guest is mr.
money mustache at mister money mustache
Pete ate me in real life he grew up in
Canada and a family of mostly eccentric
musicians then graduated from Computer
Engineering in the 1990s and worked in
various tech companies before retiring
at age thirty Pete his wife and their
now eleven-year-old son lived near
Boulder Colorado and they've not had
real jobs since 2005 this begs the
question of course how how did they do
that they accomplished this early
retirement by doing a number of things
but in effect optimizing all aspects of
their lifestyle for maximum fun at
minimal expense and by using basic index
fund investing their annual expenses on
average total a mere twenty five
thousand to twenty-seven thousand
dollars and they do not feel in want of
anything so again since 2005 all three
of them have explored a free-form life
of interesting projects side businesses
and adventures in 2011 Pete started
writing the mister money mustache blog
about his philosophy which has grown to
reach about twenty three million
different people and three hundred
million page views since its inception
since its founding it has become a
worldwide cult phenomenon with a self
organizing community and incredible news
coverage this episode explores his story
philosophies and routines so without
further ado please enjoy my conversation
with the one and only mr. money mustache
Pete
Pete welcome to the show thanks to him
it's an honor to be on here and you are
I would say in the top five most
requested guests for this podcast that
that I see on the internet and beyond I
had somebody come up to me recently in
New York City of all places and you know
you should have on the podcast and it
was you and so I'm really excited to dig
into all sorts of stories in
conversations and discussions because
I'm thinking through many areas of my
life in which I think you are an expert
or certainly spent more time ruminating
on these things but I thought we could
start with your experience getting
groceries could you describe for people
what your experience looks like getting
groceries
well it's kind of varied but I feel
strongly about groceries so and an ideal
like utopian grocery day I would throw
my bike trailer onto the back of my
single speed bike and roll down to like
the local kind of hippie natural grocery
store and then just load up with like
150 bucks of awesome stuff and then
peddle it back up the hill and then
unload it and then have people show up
and the giant barbecue that night and
feast so if that's the Utopia what does
the what does the compromise utopia look
like well it's usually pretty close to
that but sometimes people don't come
over or sometimes there's some reason I
have to use the car and maybe I'm taking
taking it past the grocery store so I
rush in and get some stuff but I think
the you know the thrust of the question
is like does this guy really get
groceries about bicycle and it's
definitely true I kind of view
everything by bike here in Longmont
Colorado like at least 99% of my trips
away from the house here are human
powered and that's just the way I've
figured out what makes me happiest to
live and at this point I'm you have a
household of three is that right yeah
that's true one boy one boy one good and
got it all right and what what is the
because I think this is this is a is
going to be a core piece of the
discussion what are your average annual
family expenses at this point would you
say all right well we've been adding
this up ever since I started writing a
blog we never really added it up before
but it always comes out around 25 to 27
thousand dollars of annual expenditures
with the notable exception that we don't
have any kind of mortgage or debt or
anything so that's all on purely stuff
that we want to buy hmm and maybe well
this is going to be memento style in
terms of chronology is a lot of my
conversations are is just a quirk of my
brain that I'm trying to bug I'm trying
to turn into a feature of this podcast
what was
the blog post or the day that you
realize mister money mustache had a
cult-like following was there and I used
that I used that in a complimentary way
by the way if you have some of the most
die-hard fans I've ever encountered
was there a particular piece or moment
when you realized how strongly have
devoted your fan base was I think it's
kind of been like one of those frog in
hot water situations where it just
gradually happens and then occasionally
especially when my friends stopping on I
like a money mustache event they're like
dude you're a cult leader did you
realize that it's but it didn't really
happen any specific time I would say the
first time I was really surprised by the
effects of blogging was when I had a
guest post on this awesome previous blog
called early retirement extreme and a
whole bunch of this Jakub bloggers fans
came over to mine my blog and just
flooded it and just crawled and read
every single article instead to put in
all these comments and then I it was
really a rewarding thing and it just
kept going from there it's sort of a
self motivating thing and then the other
incident was probably we had a party
once blog related meetup in in Ottawa
Canada which is kind of one of my
homeland hometowns and all these people
came like 200 people and it overflowed
into the backyard of this like unwitting
hosts place and it was a little weird
because I didn't even get to meet
anybody and that was the first time I
became uncomfortable with like oh well I
didn't want to be one of those people
where you don't even meet everybody who
wants to meet you so Ottawa I I've
actually spent a decent amount of time
in Ottawa the end of and I had a beaver
tail for the first time while ice
skating or planning on ice skating in
Ottawa due to start up there well quite
a large company now called Shopify oh I
knew that yeah and the beaver tail
that's the right way to do Ottawa
skating and beaver tails and now beaver
tail is
I don't even remember exactly what it is
but it's a pastry right I mean it's what
is it exactly like a chocolate-covered
pastry and for those people who have not
been to Ottawa you can you can skate for
hours I mean it's this this gigantic I
guess they lower the water level or
maybe they raise the water level so that
you can skate or effectively around the
entire city if they if I'm remembering
correctly yeah that's right and pretty
awesome the D but to get back to the
blog what what do you think has what are
the aspects of your philosophy or your
writing or your persona that have struck
such a chord well it's funny you should
ask that because the first time I ever
did a talk like a big public talk it was
to a conference of bloggers it's called
fin con and I just stopped by because it
was in Denver and I'd realized that this
blog was kind of behaving like a cult
and then I looked up like what are the
properties of a cult and then I read
some articles and maybe a book or two on
cults and I realized man I've
accidentally done it and and just
because that's my idea of a sense of
humor is so it turns out if you want to
start a cult you need to just have a few
key elements like a recognizable leader
you need to have a sense of us versus
then them you know like oh we're an
oppressed people and the rest of the
world doesn't understand us and a couple
other things that helps to feel like
you're virtuous and have some kind of
like good changing the world and the
rest of the world needs your help and
yeah so if you look at all the cults
including informal ones like Star Trek
or Apple there's always these same kind
of characteristics and I accidentally
emulated those and in retrospect
realized hey well I guess that was a
pretty good idea so for those who are
part of the US in your case what is
what's the belief system what are the
the tenets right so the belief system
which I jokingly call moustachy anism
it's kind of like a lifestyle and a fake
religion and the beliefs are that the
you know sort of the unit United States
especially is a ground zero of this
consumer
insanity that has overtaken all of our
minds and it's just causing people to
behave in an irrational way and sort of
sabotage their own ability to have a
good life for example you they work way
more years than they have to because
they're consuming a lot more crap than
they have to without actually getting a
life benefit about it over N and the
same thing applies to the health their
health in their their sanity and their
mental health or everyone's very
inefficiently going about their life so
the correction through moustachy anism
is just being a bit more thoughtful
about this stuff and seeking efficiency
in the way that you spend your money and
make sure that you get fun out of it
each time that you spend something and
applying this you just end up a lot
healthier and wealthier and able to
retire from mandatory work at a much
earlier age in your life which a lot of
people are drawn in by the prospect of
an extra four decades of freedom that
they wouldn't have otherwise gotten
correct me if I'm wrong here bu attired
effectively at age thirty is that right
right yeah this is perfect reverse
chronology just like you planned it so
yeah now we're back to the Year 2005 and
after working about a ten year career in
software engineering my girlfriend who
is now my wife and I determined we had
enough money saved up to live off the
investment returns forever so we just
quit our regular cubicle jobs and just
in time to have our baby boy at the time
and that was of course about eleven
years ago and we didn't even know this
was a weird thing to do we thought oh
yeah of course you know when you get
paid as much as we do like it only takes
so long until you don't need to work
anymore and it was only after several
years of retirement that we noticed that
we were kind of oddballs and everybody
else who are in the same amount of money
was still broke broken in probably more
way than one and and I want to dig into
some of the the numbers related to this
so as a discussion point one of the one
of the things you would set over and I
always ask guests for potential prompts
for topics that could be fun to explore
and one of them ones you only need to
accumulate 25 times your annual spending
to retire forever
could you elaborate on that and how how
you arrived at that number because I
think this is this is a useful exercise
for people to hear yeah this is a core
piece of math that is very it's widely
known if you have financial independence
enthusiast but it's almost completely
secret to most of the of the rich
world's population so if you have a if
you have a handle on your annual
spending and you know how much you need
to live on all you need to do is save up
twenty five times that amount and on the
very very conservative side let's say
twenty eight times that amount in
conservative investments like a giant
Vanguard index fund and that's enough to
fund you with passive income with a high
degree of safety if for the rest of your
life so if you have a just keep the
numbers simple if you need to thirty
thousand dollars to live on multiply
that by 25 and on give myself a tricky
math question I think that's like seven
hundred fifty thousand dollars you'd
need saved up or something like that to
quit forever and that's a lot less than
most people think most people at least
in my age group they're shooting for the
tens of millions type of range of fee if
they were to ever quit work early and
they haven't really done the math on how
easy it really is and what are there any
assumptions embedded in that in terms of
percentage annual yield and so on what
are what are the weather historically
based otherwise what are what are the
other any other assumptions embedded in
that it is yeah there's it's kind of
based on a really long-term study of the
stock market dating back to the 1920s or
something like that or maybe even
earlier and the idea is it goes up some
years it goes down some years
consistently pays dividends and in the
worst case scenario you want to still
not run out of money so that's where the
four percent comes from we've gotten you
through a lot of the worst case
scenarios there were some situations
when you could have spent up to five or
seven percent of your portfolio every
year and still not run out if you had
happen to retire just before a big stock
market boom that went on for a long time
but most people don't like taking a huge
amount of risk so
4% or 3.5 if you want to be extra
conservative with today's stock market
valuations that's more of a safety net
and it's really just a mental crutch
because what I find is that when people
retire early almost everybody like over
95% of people still have a lot of
interests and passions and then they're
pretty good at making money if they
manage to save up that much in the first
place so they still make money in their
quote retirement they just have a lot
more fun doing it and that nest egg
that's pumping out dividends and returns
just adds extra confidence so they can
can have more fun in the process well
I've read two different definitions of
retirement or maybe their
characteristics that are I think one was
attributed to you one was written by you
both of which I thought were very
helpful as a orientation for thinking
about the subject and the first is in
retirement or financial independence
simply means that you have your living
expenses covered by non work income
right part-1 yeah part two is definition
of a modern retirement the activities
you pursue once you are done searching
for money and I think it's a very useful
framework if in particular you're
considering in the early retirement at
say the age of thirty forty fifty
whatever it might be
the how do let's say media not to cast
aspersions on everyone who is part of
the existence I suppose that's what I am
right now this moment but you've been
covered a fair amount and I know like
everyone who's been covered a fair
amount you get misquoted or people get
the message wrong or they just take
Turkey cheap shots
occasionally doesn't happen all the time
you've actually had some of the most
complimentary profiles I've ever read
but where did they get it wrong where do
people get you your message your
principles philosophies wrong
well the misconceptions are for two
different things from the media side
they often assume well I mean the ones
that aren't complimentary they assume
hey there's this crazy guy and he's just
a lifestyle guru just like another jr.
Tim Ferriss trying to get everybody
excited about his crazy ideas and he's
not really retired or or they say yeah
he he made so much money but that
doesn't apply to the regular person when
they're you know when they're trying to
make it on like $50,000 a year salary or
what about people with more kids so the
media don't understand they often assume
some kind of extreme Ferg allottee that
would be undesirable to live under and
that's that's really inaccurate I worked
pretty hard to fight it because I don't
have my spending set up for the minimal
level I have it set up for the maximum
amount that I can possibly spend and get
value out of it you know because it's
easy to make money so I set my spending
at the maximum happiness level and then
stop spending when I stopped getting
more happiness so that's just that's
really the fundamental mistake and then
as for the non media world they're a
little bit more suspicious like they
just think I make every making
everything up and I don't even you know
I never did any of this stuff that I say
I did in the first place so then it's
more of a conspiracy theory if you're
reading like the comments section of MSN
is what you should never do uh you
haven't but you do have and I think this
is why it was further someone to bring
it very really a by most standards in
the United States a low household annual
expense right right and I it might be
helpful here to talk about because I
need it
I asked during our soundcheck what you
had for breakfast so can you repeat your
answer please oh yeah well my my
breakfast was a fancy black espresso at
foamed milk and coconut coconut oil
phoned into there too and then some dark
chocolate like ninety percent dark
chocolate and some nuts almonds and
cashews and stuff and it's not exact
actually related to low expenditure but
it's indirectly related I'm going to
come back to it what type but since I
love the particulars what type of coffee
what type of chocolatier halt oh yeah
well right now my coffee is some kind of
organic e Fairtrade thing but but and a
large quantity from Costco which is
obviously a lot cheaper than getting
like a Starbucks equivalent every
morning and I have an utter from Costco
as well now that you mention it so this
is the be the reason I bring it up is
that I think stumbling on happiness
stumbling on happiness by Daniel Gilbert
is is a good exploration of this
oftentimes what we think will make us
happy does not make us happy and we can
talk I we should dig into what happiness
is for you because I think it's it can
be a dangerously nebulous term but the
point being that to to have a functional
car and then to have what society tells
you is the optimal car say some type of
sports car it there's a massive Delta
and price and you pay some severe
penalties for that but you have a to go
from a good chocolate to an excellent
chocolate to world-class chocolate it
might only be the difference of ten or
twelve dollars right so there there are
there are places where you can optimize
without being obnoxious Lee or frugal or
frugal in a disabling extent and derive
maximal pleasure that's the point I was
trying to make is that yeah and what I
would love to hear from you is to those
people out there who are spending far
more multiples more than you are per
year who don't know where to start
are there any easy optimizations that
could have a dramatic impact on their
ability to get closer to optimizing for
happiness as opposed to succumbing to
internal or external pressures to remain
on this treadmill of overconsumption
yeah right and this might actually be a
better answer for your earlier question
too because as an engineer like I was
kind of born part
and for me optimization is really really
fun it's like beautiful and when
something is not optimized and when
something's inefficient I actually find
it offensive and ugly so I had a lot of
joy I get a lot of joy from looking at
each of my life spending decisions and
beam comparing it like okay if I get
this car I probably make me about this
happy and this car would make me this
one happy whereas if I ride my bike it
does this other thing and you apply that
to food and housing and transportation
and clothing travel exercise and then
all these categories can become super
efficient where you end up getting
incredible happiness out of them and the
cost can sometimes be not only low but
sometimes you'll get paid for doing
stuff that other people spend tens of
thousands of dollars to do so if you're
beginner at the sport of optimization
you can just start with the stuff that
cost you a lot of money so my favorite
one to be a bit repetitive is the car
because the average middle-income
americans spends like $12,000 per
household which is just on driving
around in these like gas-powered racing
wheelchairs and that's more than they
even invest in in their future like
that's more than they're spending on the
freedom so step one don't have a car
that's worth more than about ten
thousand bucks at the most unless you're
at least like a single millionaire
preferably multi-millionaire because you
can get a great perfectly great car that
would be trouble-free for ten plus years
for under five thousand dollars so the
reasonable ceiling would be ten and
that's already going to be a pretty
giant thing for people and then number
two is don't use that car a lot so
everybody assumes that you know a short
drive to work as anything under an hour
whereas I think I encourage people to
take a really really hard line approach
on that because it's a giant factor in
life happiness and fitness and money in
my rule is you should never get a job
you know unless you're at gunpoint that
requires you to drive to it like either
find a new job find a place to live near
that job I mean even if it requires
moving to a new city or a new country in
the long run you just got to keep that
nagging thing in your mind like okay I
drive to work now but this is not
tamal in the long run i will optimize
away card dependence and yeah just start
with that one then you can move on read
stuff on my blog and figure out how to
cut your grocery cost down and your
housing and everything like that too but
I really like the mobility because
there's Fitness involved too you know
and there's there's happiness of forcing
yourself out into the fresh air every
morning as soon as you you give up the
cage as a car such a huge thing and it's
such a overlooked thing in our country
I couldn't agree more and I think the
the it forces you to make other
decisions like you pointed out I haven't
had a car for close to three years I
want to say now that does not mean I
don't spend time in cars I do so I tend
to use whether it's get around four
trips to Tahoe or things that are
further away that requires some travel
or uber but I'd probably walk walk I
tend to walk more than I bike for
whatever reason but that's that's
typically I'd say 70 80 percent of my
locomotion sounds great walking and it's
it's helped me to make other decisions
to optimize for say having people come
to me as opposed to having to constantly
bounce around a city or travel around
the environment and think about how I
can better use the capital I have four
types of leverage that don't require or
replace the need for bouncing around
continuously and wasting that time and
transit and also found from being at
least very slower very fast in terms of
transportation work well it's in the
middle that I get very frustrated
because if it's very slow I can also say
batch phone calls I can listen to
podcasts listen to audiobooks I can take
time for that type of enrichment in the
process of moving from point A to point
B so true walking is so powerful and so
underrated like your brain just goes
into overdrive all of your problems sort
of start to solve themselves in the
background and for people who don't do
it regularly like an hour a day walking
to genuinely go somewhere they just just
discount it because they haven't even
experienced its incredible power so I'm
glad we're both on that train I ran that
shoe what are what are what are some of
the books that if this could be two
different lists but some of the books
that have had the biggest impact on you
or books that you most frequently
recommend to your readership yeah I
don't have the ultimate I'm not the
ultimate book connoisseur I don't spend
as much
I don't burn through as many books as
some people so but in recent months
three books that have had a pretty big
impact on me that I'm about to recommend
to people it really depends on who
you're talking to you so if you're into
changing the world for the better one
book that spectacularly opened up my
mind is this one called happy city but
an author called Charles Montgomery and
it kind of just pulls back the curtain
on how we're wasting most of our
resources and our human and money
resources on building up the country
into a spectacularly inefficient
ashphalt jungle so that's for urban
planning nerds and fixing the world
nerds but for people who feel like they
personally want to they're wondering
whether such a weirdo I'm a big fan of
the book on Elon Musk
by the author Ashley Vance I think it's
called Elon Musk and musk in that quest
for a fantastic future that book I read
and it talks about Ilana is a little kid
and growing up and it's like that's
exactly how I was as a kid and I thought
I was the only one and it he has this
feeling where the world is incredibly
illogical and no one's listening and he
just wants to just let him change it
like I'm just going to do everything
myself then and I could really
everything except for the fact that he
actually does it and I don't
I can relate completely to the feeling
of that book and finally a really really
old-fashioned book if someone just wants
to wake themselves up and start turning
into more of like a positive less
depressed person is this 1950s classic
called the magic of thinking big I've
recommended that to like so many friends
because I stumbled across it when I was
like 15 years old and it was really
really old even then
and that's like this this 1950 is cheesy
stereotypical like man's world has some
flaws in that way but that just makes it
more funny and it's a great way to just
remind yourself like oh when you think
big and act confident and sparkly then
it's amazing how much stuff actually
goes better for you so those are my
three so I can't comment on the first
two but I have to comment on the magic
of thinking big so I have a copy my
original copy of the magic of thinking
big about 15 feet to the side of me
right now in my living room it is one of
the books that has traveled with me and
its face out so I see it every day when
I'm alone on my couch along with a
handful of others tribe from Sebastian
Junger Doon Frank Herbert that's a bit
of a long story
gratitude Oliver Sacks I'm looking at
them right now bird by bird by animal
mods over the Greek and less-is-more
which is an anthology of writing on
minimalism and magic thinking big
but David Schwartz this book despite the
title which like you said I mean it's
it's it screens cheesy at you and it was
why it's good though in cases like
gorgeously delightfully seasoned you're
like yes I'm a powerful nineteen fifties
not as well as you're conducting
business and know exactly and it was it
was introduced to me by a man named
Steven key Steven key fascinating guy
lives in I think it's Turlock California
middle of nowhere and has built this
this fantastic career for himself
developing products a lot of toys and
licensing them to gigantic companies
whether it's Disney or Nestle Cola you
name it and he he makes these incredibly
simple prototypes out of construction
paper oftentimes and then will license
these ideas for I'm assuming hundreds of
thousands millions of dollars over time
and he was given the magic of thinking
big at one point by I believe it was a
fortune 500 CEO so the lineage at least
or the path that the book took to me was
was fascinating in and of itself and I
read it I would say around
2003-2004 which was just before I took
my my walkabout and all did all the
experimentation with my business at the
time to either redesign the business or
shut it down and that was the journey
that then precipitated the writing of
the 4-hour workweek so the magic of
thinking big I've been meaning to reread
it and part of me I don't know tell me
I'd be curious to get your opinion so I
read it so long ago and I have such a
high opinion of it that I'm worried I
will read it now and it will not age
well when I read it a second time have
you read it recently last time was
probably about five years ago and I
found it was just as good I just loved
the creat there you know the overly
simple examples like imagine that
there's two little gentlemen in your
head there's mr. success and mr. defeat
mr. defeat always wants to throw some
oil and sand into his your crankcase of
your mind and stuff like these you know
I find that most maybe this is my
engineers brain handicap again but I
really get annoyed by overly flowery
language like kind of Harper's Magazine
Atlantic stuff where people just go on
for like eight pages to cover something
that could have fit in a couple
sentences for it and dr. Schwartz
doesn't do any of that [ __ ] and in fact
his writing styles really inspired me
and like when I write as mister money
mustache I'm thinking I'm like
channeling David Jason Schwartz and he
always starts off every story with this
little anecdote like this makes him
sound like casual and powerful he's like
I was relaxing in my lounge one day when
a few of my employees came in for
questions and you know like just you
know you got to read it again I'm going
to be all right all right it's been all
my idol my to-do list for January
because I've set aside we're doing this
interview in January 2017 let's set
aside the first two weeks minimum to
simply consider options because I've in
the past
fallen prey to over calendaring myself
and for fun things in in many cases but
nonetheless
we're calendaring so I don't have as
much slack in the system empty space as
I would like and been meaning to as part
of my self-imposed curriculum reread the
metric thinking big so I will I will
jump into that how are you different
from mister money mustache if at all um
well the lines are pretty fine pretty
you know I I don't know if there's like
a really formal difference but he's
probably a bit more perfect than me like
I I'll complain occasionally and if I
don't catch myself and you know I won't
I don't actually complain on the blog
about you know when I am I add this the
world is being mean to me but in general
like because I read magic of thinking
big so long ago and internalize it so
much and I kind of ran my work career
and my you know my international
adventures of moving to the US and
everything under those assumptions I
feel like you know I'm pretty I'm fairly
mister money mustache I'm more sensitive
here's the thing like I don't lecture
people in real life about you know like
I don't actually smash my fist through
the driver window of pickup trucks and
honk the horn with the foreheads and
tell them they shouldn't be going
through the drive-thru with a stupid
off-road diesel thing but but I think it
but and I write it so yeah the mister
money mustache is a little more violent
in in his writing and in computational
and I enjoy that because it helps me
remain more calm in my real life because
nobody wants to be lectured in real life
about even if you have some ideas you
want to share with them you have to wait
for them to come to you and when you're
running a blog they have come to you by
definition which means they're a lot
more open to having their faces punched
in a literal literary sense rekted you
get to get prose mugged while you're
while you're shaping their behavior the
question of the US should be spent a
little bit of time in China and even as
a as an American who's somewhat
desensitized to consumption I think
shaatnez it appears to be 10 times more
materialistic and ended it driven
towards overconsumption but the that's
not really leading I don't wanna lead us
gently into a conversation about China
that the question I was going to ask and
have a very simple answer why did you
decide to stay in the US I just love it
here it goes
it's kind of like the furnace of the
world like many of the problems in the
u.s. that stem from under regulation are
also its strength in the sense that you
can just start stuff up and then nobody
even notices that you're doing it and
you can have a giant company before
anyone's even noticed and it's just the
entrepreneurial and the optimism and the
lack of rules is kind of it goes along
with my personality personality because
I hate rules I'm really in favor of
people self-regulating in the sense that
don't be a jerk to your neighbor and
don't pollute the world and everything
like that which is the part that annoys
me about some of the US business culture
but in general I just love it here and I
love the Giant range of geographies too
compared to Canada which is kind of just
a string of cities along the border in
the US you have a grid of cities and
islands that range from like Arctic
tundra to tropical islands and coconut
you know coconut shell tops and
everything like that if they're a lot
more variety and excitement here yeah
there is there is a lot of right here
and I've actually decided that this year
will be my year of exploration in the
domestic United States and I've realized
that might just fall to the default of
many people I think when they have their
designated time for travel or vacation
is often times to fantasize about the
trips overseas and I've realized that
neglected to explore so much diversity
in the United States itself so I'm
planning on somehow transporting me and
my pooch around the country which I am
very excited to do and next thing I'd
like to do is is
read something and get your comments on
it so this is uh this is from a piece
profile of yours in The New Yorker which
congratulations I guess it's one of the
top 16 is it most read of the year
profiles something along those lines oh
yeah yeah I saw that thanks to you I
think on Twitter I did just I might have
driven I some traffic there which which
I I was happy to do and also hesitant to
do exciting I know that there sure there
are things that are at the best
incomplete and and maybe completely
off-base at worst but that's just the
nature of the beast when you're dealing
with these types of profiles yeah I did
a snarky responses section for that like
complete on that genius IT website oh if
anybody you're in line responses yeah
that you can die writer can write his
story and then I can add my stuff right
on the side and that kind of correct for
the one-sidedness of normal New Yorker
journalism yeah I might have to do that
myself
although I'm not sure I want to reopen
the wound I was misquoted even after
correcting fact checkers I was misquoted
and number of people were misquoted
primarily half a dozen times in the
piece that I had in The New Yorker which
really rankled me because of course it's
it's the top of Google with PageRank but
yeah water under the bridge for now I'll
put that aside the piece I wanted to
read though I don't think is is going to
push those buttons let me start with the
following so being an engineer he runs
the numbers once after his bike was
apparently stolen he ruminated on the
wisdom of locking one spike and this is
this is been to your writing
this was the first steps in many many
years of very carefree living the
Craigslist replacement value of that
bike was probably around $500 what value
do I place on a decade of the fearless
freedom of leaving [ __ ] happily unlocked
and not worrying about it how about the
value of my time saved and not spending
my life fumbling with an enormous
keychain 90 seconds a day for 10 years
of 91 hours or at least $4500 in my time
at $50 an hour I'm still coming out way
ahead and you concluded if you can't
afford to lose
you can't afford to buy it yet otherwise
the object owns you rather than vice
versa and there there are plenty of
folks out there who who think we are
more opposed than I think we are because
the type of math that you did here and
I'd love to get your thoughts on it but
these are the types of things that I
think about constantly because the how
do you need how many of these wrote
decisions common decisions are burning
up the non-renewable resource of time in
the interest of some marginal utility
perceived marginal utility in terms of
dollars and cents but it I'd love to
hear any sort of thoughts or oral
aberrations that you have on this
because I love this example yeah well it
is the math sometimes explicit like that
and sometimes more implicit that drives
most of my decisions and that's why I'm
surprised like anybody who says that
mister money mustache and Tim Ferriss
are opposites in any kind of way I think
they're not really understanding the
picture because it's really just an
optimization process right like I'm not
opposed to spending money my only
limitations on spending money are number
one it has to make me happy and number
two a factor in my personal happiness is
like resource consumption because I kind
of know the numbers behind all the costs
to other people like into the earth of
everything that I buy so that kind of
rules out certain types of spending that
other non sciency non environmentalist
people might feel okay about but if you
push that bit aside it's all just about
having the maximum amount of fun so and
if you have limited money then having to
go to work for a longer time is a
genuine source of non fun and thus
spending less money is going to give you
more of something that's more fun which
is time and then you're all set so
that's a win and then now in this post
work world where I've stumbled into more
money than I could have imagined having
my spending hasn't changed and that's
just a sign that I got
some of the decisions approximately
right to begin with and and if I had
started buying more stuff afterwards
that might have been a sign that I
didn't really do the math right to begin
with what do you do with the certain
apologizer this is a simplistic question
but what do you do with the money that
you have as a surplus in this post work
life what what happens to if the
expenses aren't going up or nominally go
up and down by a few thousand dollars a
year how do you allocate the surplus
yeah that's something that's another
thing that has to be optimized because I
feel that money is such a valuable
resource so I'm still working on it so I
try to you know I've been doing small
donations like paying for more stuff
when other people I know can't afford it
and then I did a medium-sized donation
with the effect of under the effective
altruism movement that I know that
you've covered at one point in your
tools of titans book yeah ed well the
kaskell on the on the podcast the
cofounder or maybe founders of that
movement yeah and I think one of those
two founders sent me an email after I
sent my donation to them and they seemed
really really really sharp people so
that's that's one useful thing that they
with surplus money the only reason I
have some of it still sitting in my
investment accounts and it's still
rolling in of course because I still
have this unexpected blog income is I
feel like I can leverage the attention
of all these people for something good
and that would be bigger than just
donating like you know a million dollars
for whatever period to two standard
causes I think I would I would like to
create kind of like one of those tipping
point effects in the u.s. that might for
example tip us more towards bike based
turn for temptation instead of car based
you know and potentially save like
billions or trillions of dollars of
society's wealth and have it go
somewhere better if the whole society
got more excited about a different way
of living so that's why I haven't just
given away all the money yet I feel like
for example
if I could start like a little mini town
where we do things really awesomely and
this of course sounds a bit like a cults
like oh yeah we started commune but
little thing also sounds like Singapore
right yeah right in a sense of genre in
a town based on the ideas of cohousing
or something like that
so these guy ideas are still swimming
around in my head I haven't solved the
problem of how to deal with surplus
money efficiently but once I do then I
will start having some fun with it and
then I'll probably also start trying to
make more money like have the blog make
more money because I don't have a use
for it and the look to hear more about
how you your decision making process or
thought process or internal dialogue
when you are considering buying
something what are the questions that
you ask yourself and if it's related to
happiness I want to define that it may
be a way to do that is you know how do
you know when you're happy or unhappy
but I'd love to just maybe take those in
in either order really but what's the
what's the thought process like or the
internal monologue / dialogue when
you're considering buying something yeah
well usually I try to start with like no
you wienie what do you think what kind
of consumer are you you know like just a
little bit mental beatdown to shut off
the easiest things that's what keeps me
from buying like like a Tesla Model S or
something like that because even though
I think it's a great car I support it I
know for sure that wouldn't make me any
happier because I don't even have
anything to do with it like I don't
drive really so so obvious stuff gets
shut off but then when you get into like
things that you're pretty sure you want
then you just think about it for longer
procrastinate a little bit see if the
desire goes away a bit and then consider
how much space that thing is going to
take up in my my limited space of my
studio for example and then imagine how
I would feel if it broke because a lot
of stuff does break even if you have
high quality gear and it's really
annoying to deal with things things that
break and if you have to warranty fix it
and finally ask myself is this removing
a negative in my life because it's
pretty well studied
that happiness is not very much affected
by adding positives to your life it's
mostly especially in a rich world
environment like we live it's mostly
accomplished by removing things that are
strong negatives to everyday so getting
myself like a remote-control photography
drone is unlikely to make me happier
because my life doesn't currently suck
due to the absence of photography drone
a quadcopter thinnies so that's you know
and whereas if there's something that
every day I'm like dammit I just wish I
didn't always trip over this you know
broken dishwasher whatever is not then
replacing your dishwashers is probably
going to be a happiness boosting
proposition what what purchases or
productions for that matter I know you
make a lot of things but what purchases
just to stick with one category that
come to mind have most improved your
happiness by removing negatives yeah
well that's a perfect follow-up question
because I'm talking to you right now in
this studio building that I made over
the process of last year it's kind of a
thrift like a 400 square foot modernist
thing with a lot of Windows and and
overlooking this nice forested park
behind my house so I had a consistent
problem after I moved to this current
house we live in in 2013 it's a bit too
small for our styles living so I was
genuinely tripping over stuff a bit and
always having to move things around and
I had some of my equipment out in the
back like my table saw I would have to
live under a tarp
during the rare Colorado precipitation
events and I realized you know more
space would actually solve this problem
and I always wanted to have it to catch
a studio anyway to play music in because
I don't want to have to like turn off my
family's ears when I'm playing bad rock
music with my friends so I built the
studio and I did it all myself because I
know from experience that this manual
labor and solving physical problems is
one of the happiest things I can
possibly do just like you know hundreds
of hours of lifting and sweating and
digging and you know all these amazing
useful outdoor things with friends
and now I'm I'm in it you know I'm
recording a Tim Ferriss podcast in my
studio throughout of my drums and bass
and guitar and watch them the trees sway
outside so this has been a really a
genuine happiness boosting spending
expenditure of money and it's brought me
happiness pretty much from the day I
broke ground on this you know this piece
of dirt so so no regrets there even
though that was a lot more than and a
few dinners out that I spent on this
thing I've been I've been hoping and
wishing and fantasizing at some point
about building my own structure I have
not done this and I've thought about it
ever since I had Kevin Kelly on the
podcast founding editor of Wired
magazine incredible guy I mean really
the real-life world's most interesting
man in so many ways a an impeccable
technology futurist who has an Amish
beard and spends time with the Amish
till people can listen to the episode
it's a long story but I asked him what
every person should do at least once in
their lifetime and he said build a home
build a house and I every time this is a
lesson I need to relearn over and over
again I use my hands in that capacity
that manual labor reward like you said
it's it's just unbelievable even
yesterday I was I was purging donating a
bunch of stuff that I just don't need I
was I was I was getting rid of a bunch
of stuff and leave but the simple visual
reward of the before and after using my
hands to move a bunch of stuff around
and have that before there was so much
more rewarding then some of the biggest
things I've done on a laptop or on the
web in the last few months I felt
ashamed in some places it's such a
menial mundane set of tasks with civil
rewarding - yeah Kevin Kelly is right
and this is why as a fellow lifestyle
guru admittedly a junior lifestyle guru
I spend most of my time doing manual
labor even though I can make you know
infinite money type and [ __ ] into the
computer and publishing it - you know
the cult following I hardly do that at
all because the
not doesn't work for everybody but
certain people get incredible
satisfaction out of building because
it's like the Zen aspect of it there's
like physical and mental and
problem-solving it's like it's like what
a human was made to do so Kevin is right
in fact the house that I live in I also
built before I built the studio I built
as a slight exaggeration because there
was a bit of a shell I tore it down to
like a brick shell and then rebuilt it
to different shapes but and every time
like every night especially in the
winter here when it snows I look up at
the trees and like the snow falling on
the roof that I made and the fireplace
that I put in there and the heating
system that I designed pumping water
under my floors and you have my feet and
like this is the most satisfying thing I
could possibly experience so yeah you
should figure out a way to build
something at least like a shed quarters
or like a man cave type thing in your
backyard and I have this thing called
carpenter ISM where I'd go out to people
in need and build fun stuff with them
and teach them how to build so if you
ever want to do a team work Tim Ferriss
studio then I'm I'm making the software
now and make it quite an interesting
story I could I could be a like an
operating room assistant of sorts you be
like hammer hammer screwdriver
screwdriver I think I'd be more of a
liability otherwise but I'll back how
you learn though I'll give you the nail
gun and then you'll mix mistakes and
they'll bring a welder and then you like
explode some stuff but later you be
making fine welding lines and yeah you
know I might take you up on that
I love Colorado's I've been spending
more and more time in Colorado well I
was assuming we would build something at
your I say pieces of the world where you
need a structure because you don't need
to like build stuff for me that's not no
not for you I was thinking about the
people in need but maybe they don't want
like some horrible Rochas Picasso
painting of a table whether like I
didn't really want some abstract weird
it's
thing Ferris if you could you could use
parallel lines next time please in this
case you were the person in need because
you're this you know this accomplished
guy who yet has yet a hole in your life
where you haven't actually built a house
yet so so I felt sorry for you that's
all all right I will I will put a
bookmark in that I may take you up on it
here's here are a few questions related
to consumption because I think about I
do think about consumption a fair amount
living in San Francisco on some level
helps because you can't walk five or ten
feet without having talked about it or
seeing billboards are seeing
announcements and so on related to some
type of conservation or or curbing
consumption but if you a few questions
for you so the first is I and this is
related to kids so I don't have kids one
of the considerations has been a concern
for consumption so how do you reconcile
kids with consumption or do you do not
see them as dramatically increasing
these is consumptive burden oh yeah kids
are definitely a huge form of
consumption like if you're a rich world
resident and you have a kid you know
that's that's another hundred years of
rich world lifestyle going on there so
but I'm not a pure person I
strategically in indulge in fun stuff
and and my wife and I knew we wanted to
have kids and we just happened to feel
that one was the right number for us and
I'm not judgmental of against other
people but I think it's just good it's
one of the things to throw into your
equation of like child raising like
should I have one or maybe thirteen we
like well if is consumption of natural
resources that is a factor you might not
have thirteen but if it's not a factor
you know no judgement for me and so we
got one and then you can have probably
like a four X you know four hundred
percent difference in the amount of
consumption you do on behalf of your
child
depending on how you raise them
depending on what activities they're
into and what kind of stuff you buy them
and how you train them as well if you
train them like hey we're rich and rich
people get to buy whatever they want
then you're going to raise a super
consumer and more the richer you are
whereas if you teach them into the
balance and give them a little bit of
biology and science in their upbringing
then they're going to have a value
system that prevents them from being
nearly as destructive and yet they'll
probably still have more fun in the
world as well is it true that you paid
your son per mile ridden on his bike at
one point yeah we still do that there's
just kind of a I like this by the way
this is not in any way a criticism right
every parent many of them like to find
excuses to give their kids money in
order for them to figure out how to
manage it at a young age so I didn't
want to just hand over money like your
money comes from nowhere so I thought
that bicycling would be kind of little
income system for him so he has an
odometer on his bike so it automatically
tracks for miles and then just give him
ten cents a mile which adds up pretty
fast if you're an all bicycle family so
I'm just giving a little payouts and
then we've got a spreadsheet where we
keep trackers money he's 11 years old by
the way and and that our interest so he
has a comparison of like if I keep my
money in the bank of dad that I'm going
to earn interest with I spend it my
capital decreases and then that
interest-bearing piece of like my little
green employees are gone forever so he
still spends his money of course but he
just knows everything's a trade-off
which is makes it more more thoughtful
now you are an engineer and it seems
like you have a strong engineer genetic
through-line in your family as your son
tried to Ferris Bueller the odometer at
any point of course doing the opposite
has he figured that had had a tinker
with his odometer or I guess is he so
good that perhaps you wouldn't have
noticed yeah I mean you never know he
might hook it up to a cordless drill and
spinning that front wheel
no I don't think he's not that's not in
his personality like he's not into
really cheating on anything
he's plus it's kind of an abundance like
he has more money than he can spend a
little dude has like a thousand bucks in
house a spreadsheet now and the only
thing he really wants to buy is the odd
video game which might be like twenty or
thirty dollars once every few months so
he's pretty much retired already because
the passive income the he's earning is
uh is close to finding his videogame
needs either that or he's got the best
long con in history like he's been he's
been conning you with his good behavior
for 11 years just to just to tinker with
this odometer which I don't think is the
case but for those people who are
listening and I'm sure you're asked this
all the time but books on investing or
personal finance are there any go to
recommendations they don't have to be
books they could be resources but for
people who want to self-educate
could certainly be one of your top you
know one or two blog posts as well but
if you were to pick from potentially
your own stuff but also from other work
that's out there where would you direct
people I think it depends on how
interested in investing you are one of
the key nice things about the world
especially the US financial system is
you don't have to know much to be a very
good investor like you can be a top 10%
investor by just buying one Vanguard
fund and leaving your money just putting
all your extra money in there forever
so if you're if that's your idea of good
enough which it should be for most
people then you can just read any book
by Jack Bogle John Bogle the founder of
Vanguard is one good example a friend of
mine or the blogger named Jim Collins
wrote this book called a simple path to
wealth which is just sort of like a even
simpler more story-based
like enjoyable old man's tales
explanation of how why you should invest
in index funds and so that's another
idea but much more important than how to
invest as long as you don't screw up
your investing like leave your money
checking account or by a shifty
life-insurance whole life program or
whatever you know the things that
swindle people out of their money you're
going to be fine on the investing side
so the other side of that equation is a
book and I really want to try to book
myself so then I can just recommend my
own but for now it's a really great one
it's called your money or your life that
everybody's heard of and if you just get
your get the whatever the latest edition
of that book is it really teaches you
philosophy that's pretty similar in mine
which is that consumption is not really
what's making you happy buying yourself
treats and and it's quite easy to become
financially independent as soon as you
modify your spending in that way so a
huge surplus of money is on a weekly or
monthly basis is the real solution to
your financial problems rather than
becoming a super kick-ass investor yet
there's a book that I read I'll if
you've ever read this book it does
primarily focus on low cost index funds
if I remember it correctly but I Daniel
Solon the smartest investment book
you'll ever read
oh yeah heard of it and I had a quite
enjoyed that book is a little more
nuanced certainly anything my Bogle is
is fantastic for people who want to dig
deeper there any additional books that
you would recommend or that you've
enjoyed yourself yeah if you want to get
deeper like for example more into the
Warren Buffett side of things where
you're an active investor um
one really interesting book that I read
a few years ago is called the little
book that beats the market and it's
really a lesson on investing value
investing fundamentals how to understand
if a company actually is a good deal to
buy and that helps put a regular you
know like a sober shell around investing
instead of the ridiculous speculation
like technical chart investing I think
is kind of universally proved to be bunk
but people are still doing it like oh
you have a Bollinger Bands or well this
week I'm going to you know I see a
support level at fifty three point five
unless something happens like all that
stuff is statistic
it keeps being proven wrong and people
keep doing it so don't do that if you're
going to be an active investor then get
really good at understanding companies
rather than technical fluctuations and
that's why Warren Buffett makes a lot of
money above the rocket returns because
he's a savant in understanding business
and some people genuinely are that like
maybe it would probably be less than one
in a thousand people we'd likely leave
that he's also savant in emotional
detachment in the sense that I'd love to
talk to you a bit about stoves and so on
at some point but he is utterly
unaffected by what he would call mr.
market at the ups and downs of any given
company that he may have bought in the
form of shares or outright if he
purchased the entire acquired the entire
company and that type of emotional
detachment is also exceptionally
exceptionally rare yeah and that goes
without saying to me that's a
prerequisite you I don't I don't have
that at all so I auction what well no in
the sense that if I'm going to be active
it is very hard for me to be an active
investor in publicly traded equities for
whatever reason I can do highly
speculative startups and that's a
disturbingly high percentage of my
portfolio because I can't balance a
portfolio with illiquid assets it's very
challenging certainly but with with
publicly traded equities if I'm trying
to be active in any capacity I do very
poorly emotionally with those
fluctuations and I make bad decisions
okay but if we're talking about
something like an index then I'm fine if
it's if it's exhibits and if it's
entirely hands-off and I have other
people or in some type of say automated
fashion with whether it's a wealth front
or something else then I don't have any
trouble with it
yeah okay yeah that's um since I don't
do active stuff anymore and that's I'm
totally would agree with you on that in
agreement the the book you mentioned was
that by Joel Greenblatt the little book
that beats the market yeah that's right
yeah it was really interesting and it
was a little book which is perfect for
my short book attention span he is yeah
Joel is is exceptionally he's an
exceptionally short guy and he has a
fascinating track record because he he
can teach and he has taught in in
classrooms in New York at universities
he can write and he's also very very
well respected and it's not only a value
investor but also an invented what you'd
call an event-based investor so his
first book I think it was his first book
is perhaps the most sophisticated of
them all which is where people can make
the most mistakes so I think the little
book that beats the market makes more
sense as a first rate or maybe the his
later book the big secret for the small
investor but look with the title that is
sort of blessed and cursed in the same
way that the 4-hour workweek just sounds
so schlocky as if it's going to appear
at 3:00 in the morning on an infomercial
that it's but it's highly memorable so
it's been helpful in punishing at the
same time he has a book called you can
be a stock market genius which is
actually really sophisticated I've met
some of the most successful and most of
by the way hedge fund managers are not
successful but I the handful I've met
who have been exceptionally successful
this book which is intended for novices
effectively is one of their favorite
books so lots of lots of yeah lots of
interesting stuff out there and I'm
going to check that one out for sure
since I like Joel Greenblatt's writing a
lot and I still follow you know I read
an investment in finance books all the
time I just try not to recommend them
too much on my blog because it's
supposed to be about lifestyle and
making your life good and I don't want
it to be all esoteric but sure why
wouldn't you should like the Timothy
Geithner book stress test I read that
800 page description of the financial
crisis and I was sounded pretty
captivating knowing what really happened
in the background but you know for the
average person it's not
going to help them get rich and retire
earlier so I don't talk about it too
much well on top of that if you want a
cautionary tale so for those of you out
there who love loves love reading at
least if a book is captivating what you
should get at the same time if you
decide to get v you can be a stock
market genius by Joel Greenblatt which
is exceptional you should also read a
book that will be a cautionary tale and
it's a cautionary tale because it it
details the types of people that you are
competing against if you choose to be
really active in certain respects and
it's a fantastic read it's more money
than God and it is about the birth of
the hedge fund model and a number of the
characters and most successful managers
in that world it's a bit like a liars
poker but instead of bonds they're
talking about hedge funds and it will
give you a very good idea of who you are
competing against and when you step on
when you step onto the metaphorical golf
green and you throw your money down as
your participation and bet on yourself
the fact that Tiger Woods is probably to
hold you becomes super super clear and I
should also and just to in a sense
reinforcement you said about index funds
say when I went to the only time I had a
chance to go to the Berkshire Hathaway
shareholders meeting in Omaha Nebraska
and I think they've stopped doing open
Q&A with Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger but I actually ran in and it's
insane I mean it is like a gigantic rock
concert for investment nerds and people
will camp out overnight to try to get a
good seat and I ran in and I was
someone's guest which was great because
I was able to get in a little earlier
than the entire the entire stadium full
of folks effectively and I ran in and I
found somebody who was volunteering or
working there and I said which
microphone is the hardest to get to
because they had microphones
all throughout this this venue and
that's where you would be able to ask
your question if they got to you and I
figured you know what people are going
to be long-winded maybe the answers
would be long-winded although they very
seldom are especially if Charlie
Munger's involved and I need to find a
micro a can be first or second person in
line and so I ran up went through this
crazy set of staircases and found this
mic that was in the mobile knower and I
asked Warren Buffett if you were 30 and
I said the hypothetically if you were 30
you had say five hundred thousand
dollars to a million dollars in savings
and there were a couple of other
stipulations but what would you do with
the money and he's and he said assuming
you're not a professional investor I
would put it into the S&P 500 or in an
index fund and get back to work that was
it that was the end of the cancer and
you know Charlie do you have anything
more to add nope and then on to the next
question so yeah it's good advice it is
because there's so much more to work on
in your life like if you're going to
become a really good investor you're
probably going to compromise in the
areas of being a good parent or being a
good maintaining good physical fitness
or and life like you're not really
optimizing you're not supposed to
optimize for money you're supposed to
optimize for happiness which has a lot
of dimensions so you should really like
take the sort of the four-hour investor
your approach and be like everyone says
this is good I'm just going to do it and
I'm going to work on all the other stuff
in my life that also needs to be
addressed yeah well let's let's jump
into some some rapid-fire questions as I
call them but your answers don't need to
be short I'll just try to keep my
long-winded question a shot to a minimum
so outside of your media family when you
hear the word successful who's the first
person who comes to mind for you or
who's a person who comes to mind for you
oh boy yeah I've racked my brain over
this question because I know it's a
standard Ferriss podcast question and I
don't have a answer than anybody would
recognize because I can't judge the
success of any celebrities or well-known
people
because success is such a balanced thing
and it depends on how happy you are at
home and how nice you are to the people
who are close to you so to me the people
in my life that I've seen seem to be
very high in success range are a couple
of friends these are male friends that
run their own business they basically
both fit into the same description so
they run their own business
they're a little bit older than me their
business is extremely successful but
they've scaled it right right back in
order to be a lifestyle business and
hand it off a lot of responsibility to
their employees and that kind of pay
them more because there's so much
surplus anyway and you're like okay you
deal with all the junk in exchange for
you never calling me in the weekend
so both these friends work pretty
minimal like 10 to 20 hours a week and
yet somehow their businesses keep doing
better because of this hands-off
approach so they're making even more
money but you have to have a fairly
mustache ian's lifestyle and this is
probably because I met these guys
through the blog and then they both have
kids and they have really really good
relationships with their children
they're semi adult children and their
wife and basically just really good
shape physical shape they do a lot of
adventures they always say yes if I
invite them to do something they're like
oh yeah sure will we'll fly over and
meet you in that random spot for some
mountain biking or whatever so they've
they've managed to combine all of these
dimensions of what most people want in a
kind of a carefree way and and they're
not overly focused on any one of them
which allows them to be extremely fun
people to be around so that's my
definition of success and that's what I
kind of hope for for myself by the time
I'm like 50 years old with a pretty old
kid we are waiting on the flipside we
talked about what some of the critics
get wrong what perhaps media sometimes
misinterpret where do where your fans
get it wrong what are the most common
mistakes that your readers make or
misinterpretations they wind when do
they get the message wrong that's pretty
rare I find it's a pretty I write a lot
of stuff right so anybody who reads a
lot they'll see all the little
nuances and bits and what I try to
express as a philosophy but for those of
them those readers who don't have all
the details a lot of people assume that
I'm very you know I like I would be mad
at them if I ever found out that they
bought something luxurious like oh don't
tell mister money mustache I bought this
$2,000 mountain bike because I really
love bikes but but you know everything
else is good and like I don't I don't
judge people to nearly the standards
that they think I judge them let's see
so and the other thing is the same for
people who don't know my real life they
often assume that it's pretty Spartan
and and that I'm always any pinching and
this goes back to the same answer with
The New Yorker article too but um and
I'm really I'm really in favor of of
celebrating and decadence and feeling
like stuff is luxurious so so I'm really
not as minimalist as people people think
I am I'm really maximalist in the fun
department besides the studio what are
some of those luxuries and we could tie
that into you let's limit it to
purchases that have most positively
impacted your life or that you just love
because they're so damn fun for you what
what is what are some of those things
well some of the some of those vacations
so since since retiring from real jobs
my wife and I have had a nice tradition
of going somewhere semi-tropical every
winter for a good long period most
winters at least sometimes the school
schedule messes it up a bit but but yeah
for a month or more will often go and so
we spend some money on these vacations
and we'll rent a nice house on a beach
like in Florida or Hawaii or Costa Rica
or whatever so vacations most of the
money goes to rent basically like VRBO
type stuff Airbnb sure there's one
example of indulgences that I still have
a lot of warm memories from and I really
like knowing that I can do that at any
time so even when I'm not on vacation
right now in January and sometimes if
the cold weather blows in I think and I
could just press a few buttons on this
computer and just fly right out
to anybody's VRBO and be there within
like a day or two and just having that
freedom is a form of luxury itself and
then I can go out and shovel some snow
and be happy about it and yeah the other
purchases nothing's really expensive but
when I built out the current house the
main house rather than the studio I was
feeling pretty rich at the time so I I
went a bit high-end on some of the stuff
like I have this really gorgeous high
efficiency wood burning wood stove
fireplace thing that brings me pleasure
every day even though is more expensive
than you know than just a basic
fireplace and the window is in my house
for example are very kind of these fancy
windows that cost about five times more
than then it would have cost to fight
you on bare bones so it's usually stuff
related to home vacation and food you
know we've been known to go out for
sushi a bit more than a person in debt
should go into sushi so we take
advantage of our non debt status its
roots really not too much though yeah do
you have any favorite documentaries or
movies my favorite I'm actually got a
huge huge list of documentaries that
I've been meaning to watch many of them
collected from the from the guests on
your tools of Titan's book but the one
that I did watch and enjoy is actually a
series with an documentary but the
cosmos does the reaming of asthma
Neil deGrasse Tyson yeah I love Neil
deGrasse Tyson and I love his awkward
but scientific way and the topics he
covered in those in those episodes were
like so stunning and it was a great
education for my son who is very very
into science himself so that's kind of
like that's the documentary that stands
out in my mind it's a great probably the
most interesting thing in the last five
years anyway yeah so that is a fantastic
series I've been hoping and meeting to
have Neil on the podcast we've had I
guess some some indirect email exchanges
so if anybody's good buddies with Neil
give them a poke and let them know that
I'd still like that more the podcast oh
yeah
if you were to give a TED talk on
something that you are not known for
what would you give it on any any kind
of pet obsession or something your
lesser nose where maybe your diehard
fans have read every single line of
everything you've ever written would
have heard of it but yeah if you had to
guy I think I do have an answer yeah if
you define the thing that I'm known for
is the early retirement mister money
mustache stuff then the other topic that
I'm super passionate about is is energy
and like the world energy balance and
solar power and how the human how humans
consume it now we can basically fix our
energy consumption related to climate
change and all this stuff so I probably
write one up about that and explain how
we're at this insanely close tipping
point where fossil fuels are just about
to be economically unfeasible even
without regulations and stuff and I
think that can make a good tight duck
because a lot of people are you need to
popularize the ideas and right now
they're kind of dry and numbers base
like you're talking about terajoules and
kilograms co2 and all this stuff and
there's a lot more fun and emotion in
that topic if you if you package it
right so I think that'd be a good talk
yeah what is your what what I've been
curious about I know you've written
about this before but when you are if
you if you were to think of when you and
your when you were in your best physical
shape in the last five years what did
the exercise regimen look like I saw a
photograph of you I want to say
squatting outside an outdoor squat rack
am i making that up
yeah that was my most recent blog post
okay I try to get a little old now but
yeah so you
in fact when you're in the best shape
and you can define that anyway you like
what what your exercise regimen look
like yes I might be in in some ways in
some of the best shape I'm in my life
right now and that is just a pretty
casual program but with really efficient
barbell exercises combined with just a
whole bunch of walking and biking
construction so so the the barbell stuff
is just squats deadlifts clean and press
a little bit of benching and then stuff
with kettlebells and dumbbells and
generally using weights that I can just
barely lift five times and the total
expenditure per week is only in the
order of like an hour or two so I'm not
like a gym rat so that's right now I'm
pretty happy with the way my body is
working especially for a 41 year old or
whatever am but the strong I was
slightly stronger when I was in my 20s
and it was basically the same stuff but
just going to the gym for a longer
period and training it was really just
more hours put in and that's when I
probably had my record weightlifting in
certain exercises give me a quote or any
quotes that you live your life by or
think of often don't really think in
quotes too often maybe with the
exception of use it or lose it seems to
come up at least a couple times a day
haha
I'd say that's often enough to to be a
yes so short and and thus memorable you
don't have to be all flower info poetic
to appreciate lose use it or lose it but
I think it's because in the current
stage of my life being over 40 and then
having some family members with you know
some people have died and my family and
had serious health problems like in the
extended family and it's really made me
a more aware of mortality and how stuff
doesn't automatically stay in perfect
condition and even if even if it does
stay in perfect condition you're
unlikely to live forever unless some
really really big medical stuff changes
before I turn 100 so anyway I usually
lose it is
is the philosophy like brain body skills
friendships relationships just do
everything that you want to be good at
as often as you can and don't fool
yourself that you're going to keep being
able to do this stuff unless you
continue doing it regularly in the
and I don't know which label to use here
but in the safer gala T or low-cost
living world what is the worst advice or
what is bad advice that you hear given
the often I think the biggest issue with
that I have with a lot of mainstream
financial advice is that they're they
make you think of saving as a negative
kind of a negative obligation they're
like yeah we know it feels a lot better
to buy yourself treats but oh come on
like if you can just squeeze out 5% or
even 10% then you're you're doing okay
just do that every week and make a
budget and all this stuff and so you're
you're training people to think that
saving is bad and you want to minimize
it whereas I think it's a win-win and
most of our spending is is the sign of
weakness and it's a bunch of stuff that
we do to compensate for our weaknesses
because we couldn't solve the problem in
a smarter way like as we talked about
earlier it's possible to walk or bike to
work which is a physical and mental win
and it just happens to cost a lot less
so I encourage people to radically
reshape their entire lifestyle to be
optimized in all these dimensions and
sure you happen to save 50 to 75 percent
of your income as a as a by-product but
the only reason that's a win is because
your life is better as well and normal
financial advices doesn't really address
a life stuff and you know you see a lot
of these totally out of shape business
guru people trying to sell life
insurance at the same time as they're
giving you financial advice and they're
not really you know they're not really
in it for making people's lives better I
think that's where that's where it falls
flat
yeah for sure and yeah it's uh important
I think certainly in almost every area
but in the world of financial planning
and advice to ensure that the person
giving the advice has done what they're
suggesting
or has some practice putting their words
into action because otherwise they have
stress test their ideas or at the very
worst they're hypocrite and they're
doing the opposite of them
are there any failures that come to mind
which are favourite failures of yours in
the sense that they ended up selling the
seeds of a later success is anything
like that come to mind for you yeah I
have a pretty pretty serious one that I
call I have an article called mister
money mustache is big mistake and it's
right after I retired in 2005 I kind of
faded in to a my first dream retirement
job which was to start a custom house
building company where I was going to
make these beautiful eco-friendly houses
I did actually we started making these
houses and and the problem was it was
way way more stressful than than what I
wanted for a retirement job and I just
had this new baby boy at the same time
and suddenly I had all these obligations
and like a construction loan to build
this thing and I was doing marketing and
working late and wrangling all these
cats together like the contractors to
help out building the places and it
wasn't really retirement at all and on
top of that we did it the right time for
the housing crisis so like we sold our
first house into the 2006 boom market
for housing but then by the time the
second one was done this 2007 and
everything was slowing down and then
starting to drop like a rock and then I
was stuck with this beautiful ready to
sell house and nobody wanted to buy it
for any kind of reasonable sum so that
was kind of soiled the fund spoiled the
fun of my first three years of
retirement is running this company at
the same time though going through
hardship was was really good for me I
had to do a lot of hard stuff that I
wouldn't have done and that's how I
learned a lot of my best carpentry stuff
you know the skills that I'm most
skilled my most proud of is like as I've
always messed around with woodworking
since I was a little kid but by being
forced into production on these expenses
modernist houses where everything has to
be perfect
it really trained me a lot and I enjoy
those skills now so the combination of
shittiness and skills and then then we
shut this company down and since then
I've been
Trulli retired and had so much more fun
looking back and like wow I'm sure glad
I'm not doing that anymore
so it lost a bunch of money you know
some of my retirement savings went up in
smoke initially and then I was started
to be a bit more worried about money
that was a big part of it because I was
like oh all my hard-earned savings and
if I could go back and change that I
would probably still do it but I would
train myself to be just so much more
relaxed about it and be like dude don't
worry you're going to have so much fun
after this and you're not going to write
on the money so just have a good time
with your business even if even if it
fails what was the process like of
shutting it down in the sense that was
there a particular dinner or
conversation or bike ride or moment when
you decided to start the process of
shutting it down and how did that what
did that look like well it was pretty it
was pretty quick because I bought these
two vacant lots in kind of a premium new
urbanist neighborhood with my business
partner in the and the company and then
we started building the first one and it
was the four mentioned stress was high I
was like oh Sh
what has I got myself into okay let's
just get these things done and then be
done with it
so then I got the first one done and
then like whew that was great you know
big success that sold for more than we
were even asking for it and then the
second one got more and more stressful
and I already knew before I even started
that second one that I wanted to shut
down the business afterwards it just got
drawn out longer and then we got into
like renting it out but then the tenants
turned out to be horrible and I had
these like scam artists move in that we
didn't realize were scam artists and
they were like oh yeah we got we just
sent you the rent yeah it's in your
mailbox check your mailbox click and
hang up and all these like little tricks
and the guy had like this you know fancy
like brand-new Corvette that he had
bought and he had to hide it in the
garage because the repo man would take
it back if he ever saw it outside but
all he could do is like pull it out
polish it and rev it and then put it
back in the garage these people were
just really messed up and I happened to
get tangled in their web for a while
we had to use the full-on eviction with
like sheriff coming to the door to get
him out of my place and so yeah there's
some education in there
it sounds like attic ha what did it feel
like when was it finally done shut down
completely what did what did that day
feel like I'd say it was shut down one
of the biggest problems with this is
that the the relationship between me and
my friend who started a business partner
it just soured and it became pretty bad
by the end and we had totally different
views about work and money and dividing
stuff up so we finally got him out of
there by I basically had to buy out the
company I had to put like I had lost all
this money and I had to put like a final
four hundred and sixty thousand dollars
into the company to pay off this
mortgage that was on the house just to
kick him off the deed the property deed
so that I could have control of it so
that day was kind of like you know we're
like frowning at each other over the
lawyers table or whatever and then since
then that that lifted the weight off of
me and then everything was so much
better and then for a while I rented out
the house to great tenant and had it in
that situation I was just using the rent
for kind of our grocery money because
that house was a fairly big portion of
our retirement savings income at the
time and then more recently I think just
less than two years ago I the market in
our area here in Colorado starts a boom
again so I just sold it for a nice high
price and then now I've been super
relaxed and then that's kind of like
another wave and it really taught me a
lot about happiness because this
negativity in my life
at least I was choosing to perceive it
negatively it was washed away and then
suddenly I was happier than I could have
ever imagined being because I'd gone
through this somewhat hellish situation
and then remove the negative okay yeah
which is such a valuable question I be
the question to ask for purchase this
did that that alone will
returned a hundred ex the effort of
scheduling and doing this interview for
me that question is this removing a
negative from my life it's such a
powerful reframe because I think that is
so true and so so incredibly useful but
did the next which is going to be
completely flipping that on its head and
this is not one of my usual questions
but I'm so curious to know how he will
answer this if you had had to spend you
were given a hundred thousand dollars
and they said you have to spend this you
have to buy something or some things you
cannot donate donate it to charity
you cannot stick it into an investment
vehicle you have to spend it and it has
to be on you your family or your close
friends but it can't be charitable in
the sense that you're paying for the
college tuition of your friends kids and
so on nothing like that how how would
you spend that what would you do it that
was my answer you just took my answer I
know because I felt like it was going
because I could pay off some of these
mortgages there's still one family
member in my close family that has a
mortgage but so yeah we want we want to
consume here um yeah it can have more
than a hundred thousand we're sure no
it's about limited it's not limited this
is just let's just say that you took a
step into bizarro land where everything
was what it wasn't and suddenly you are
the anti mustache right yeah and look
what would you do well the thing is this
might actually be somewhat realistic
because I still consider everyday you
know is there something I could spend
money on that would be worth it it's
still an open question you don't want to
be ideological about this stuff but so
one thing I've been interested in maybe
buying and if I was forced to I would do
it quickly is a is a building I kind of
want to own a commercial building on our
towns little historic Main Street this
town I live in
Longmont Colorado is kind of one of
these over 100 year old things where
it's all historic with big trees and the
narrow Main Street with the tall brick
buildings on it so I could buy one of
those and then set up you know some kind
of fun community space in there where we
we play music and we have parties and we
rent it out and do some teaching too
because I like to do a bit of volunteer
math and science teaching to the kids
kind of advanced stuff that they don't
get in the normal school so I could have
like professor mustaches a school of
Science in my downtown building so that
does be kind of a fun use of money yeah
this is more of course a metaphorical
question but if you could have one
gigantic billboard anywhere with
anything on it would say you know short
message or image that you would like to
impart to the world right I'm picturing
this in a u.s. metropolis because that's
kind of where I'm focusing my efforts
right now so I think I would say I think
we'd say walk or maybe you'd say just
walk something that people can really
understand quickly look at without
getting yeah back to our original
thoughts like the sea under it's the
best prescription medication in the
world and yet it's so under done so far
so it's my billboard yeah it we've made
as a species so many evolutionary
trade-offs to be able to walk with a
level head unlike say a pig that doesn't
have a nuchal ligament so their heads
bobble over the places we've evolved to
be able to as they would seem a survival
imperative walk very long distances and
I just feel like humans are generally
better human and less neurotic when they
walk a lot at least that's true for me
I'll speak for myself I'm like 10
percent less neurotic yeah which is
which is the win for me that's where a
billboard could say just walk you've
paid a high evolutionary price for this
ability and let's not squander it what
what are what are one of your biggest
challenges right now how do you plan to
think about it or face it I think my
biggest challenge is the over satisfied
rat in a cage syndrome where it's a fine
line between being too satisfied you buy
your life with your life and not doing
enough
so that you feel like a bit of a weenie
at the end of the day for squandering
one of the few days of your life versus
over driving yourself to be like well I
got to accomplish more you know I have
all these gifts and great situations
that I have to make the most of it and
taking either of those two extremes
um can lead to a pretty unsatisfying
life and this often I often compare
myself actually because this is a little
bit weird but to you as Tim Ferriss
because I've read some of your books and
I see some of your self reflection in
there where you have some of these
battles you're like well should I be
perfectionist or should I relax and I
have a lot of these same questions to
myself and one of the differences is
that I chose to have a kid and I focus a
lot of energy on that which by
definition subtracts a lot of the other
stuff I could do like why am I not
running my own kind of Tesla type
company or whatever so that's my
challenge is is trying to walk the line
and have the at the end of each day be
satisfied that I've created the right
balance of like stress and
accomplishment versus lazy decadence
which is part of the fun of really being
early retired is that you generally can
like just smoke a bowl and have some fun
with your friends on a Wednesday and
like sleep in and it does not matter and
you still are going to have all the
money that you need no matter what so
and it's still yeah I still have trouble
I've been a little bit on the lazy side
in the last couple weeks because of
family conditions here at home and so
I'm I'm craving to get back to work on
something hard how will you how do you
think you'll explore that in the coming
year testing that balance or trying
different things to try to find it or
maybe it's maybe it's a matter of just
oscillating between the poles and that's
how you achieve balance it's not like
you're never it's not like you're over
50/50 for a long period of time you just
oscillate between the poles I don't know
but how are you thinking about that
because I'm also thinking about the same
thing in 2017 yeah well it's a
continuing series of experiments and
it's always changing look I've been at
this for a long time it's been 11 years
since I had a real job and I've done a
lot of hard stuff and then a medium
amount of laziness in this time so I
keep trying stuff to see if I enjoy it
so like last August for example I wanted
to see if I enjoyed the TED talk kind of
public speaking and I did a whole bunch
of traveling around that as well and I
found it was a bit too much like I
enjoyed the actual stuff that I did but
I was craving being at home and then
that's made me realize that most of my
joy comes when I'm actually creating
something and this is one I'm less
travel oriented than other people
because I can't really create while I'm
traveling so I need to do a certain
amount of like nitty gritty construction
and design and just hanging out and
having fun unplanned spontaneous people
coming over for a party or barbecue or
whatever so I need this village life
whew imagine a primitive man living in a
village where he spends half of time
hunting some of the time like building
stuff and some of the time reveling
around the fire that's kind of my core
of happiness and when I get too much
into lifestyle guru activities like I'm
going to publish more articles or get
this book done quickly or say yes to all
these interviews so I can have more and
more fans and pageviews those things
sound actually they sound dumb when I
say it like that but when you look at so
you know when you look at news headlines
about yourself you're like that's
successful or you look at page views or
money you oh yeah that's success but
it's actually good kind of a least happy
thing that I do it's the least
satisfaction bringing so I have to
balance that with with these much more
villagey type of activities but if I do
if I totally neglect the internet world
then I'll feel like I'm letting the
world down because you can actually
create good positive change that way
that you could never do just in your own
village right what have you changed your
mind on in the last handful of years is
there anything that you've done an
about-face on in any way or modified
substantially in your thinking
there's been a few little things like
what type of eating is healthy
kind of switch to the high fat low carb
eating on a whim after reading some
books and I'm really really happy with
that
whereas before when I was a teenager I
was the ultimate low fat because I read
all these bodybuilding magazines back
then and oh yeah and they were always
telling you like oh yeah 10 grams of fat
would be way too much than all this
stuff so that was a change in a little
way the biggest change I've had though
is more in my understanding of happiness
I thought the happiness came from from
maximum achievement and maximum wealth
and as I got into experimenting with
those things sounds too much alike my
other answer but I learned much more
about the balance that's required for
happiness so it's changed my goals for
the rest of my life is that there's a
lot more to happiness than just being
maxed out in one dimension so I only
have a few questions left I'm having a
lot of fun of me we keep going for many
many hours but do you have any ask or
request of my audience
any experiment you'd like them to do
exercise anything it could really be
anything but any any parting thoughts
before I ask you where people can find
out more about you and so on right well
if you are new to this stuff that I talk
about then I would suggest and if any of
anything that I am advocating sounds
crazy like for example not using a car
to get your groceries or not using car
to get to work then try it and think of
the idea of voluntary hardship to put
this phrase into your mind and then see
where you can apply it through the day
and then you're like hey that looks hard
I think I'm going to do it instead of
that looks hard I'm going to try to
avoid it and the voluntary hardship is
that the gateway drug to the rest of
moustachy anism and thus being able to
save 75% of your Silicon Valley income
while everyone else is still broke so
yeah find some things that are hard even
if it's just skipping the elevator and
and taking the stairs like up to the
dancefloor or whatever just if the other
people are not doing it and that's
probably a sign that it's something that
you should do and and just record your
results see how much better it makes you
feel and then just keep pushing yourself
bit further I echo that and spin it
slightly differently it's not these are
complimentary viewpoints but even if
people listening those folks out there
listening if you do not want to focus on
saving even if that is not the objective
per se voluntary hardship is a fantastic
way to short-circuit hedonic adaptation
where you need more and more and more
almost like an opiate to satisfy your
need for X and I would highly recommend
everybody read a letter you can find it
in the public domain online I can also
find it in tools of Titan's in a
slightly edited fashion but on festivals
and fastings letters thirteen from
Seneca Seneca the younger to Luc ILI's
the moral letters to looky-loos on
festivals and fasting and it talks about
setting aside a few days per month let's
say to experience voluntary hardship in
different ways and it is it is such a
fascinating psychological tricks in in
many respects with all sorts of
beneficial side effects like cutting
down on expenses that I think allows you
to realize it is possible to recalibrate
yourself to experience greater happiness
and well-being without simply adding
more more and more more and more
whether that's pageviews money fancy
[ __ ] you don't need or otherwise so I
definitely want to second that notion
keep where can people find out more
about you and you've written a lot where
should they where should they start also
so where can they find you on social
learning they say hi where can they read
your stuff and where should they start
if if they're they're just opening the
doors to your writing I'm a big fan of
old-fashioned website so there's always
mister money mustache calm and you'll
see start here button on there and it
takes you con F to an introductory
article and then the design of the
website to the limited extent that it
has a design is just to poke around and
follow links to other links and or you
can start at the beginning and read all
the 400-plus articles dating back to
2012 or 2011 and yeah that's how most
people do it and then you can read it if
you get really into the rabbit hole then
there's a full room where like all these
users discuss their intimate problems
with each other and it's got like tens
of thousands of members that spend all
day on there and or you can just for
keeping it really light you can just go
to Twitter and look up mister money
mustache and say hey I enjoyed the
podcast perfect Oh Pete thank you so
much for the time I really appreciate
you taking the time and to everybody
listening as always you can find that
links to everything we discussed books
and otherwise at the show notes which is
for this episode and every other episode
4-hour workweek com forward slash
podcast all spelled out for our work
week on for lunch podcast and as always
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday the vent provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday's a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high end financial advice that the
best private wealth managers deliver to
ultra wealthy but for any account size
and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealthfront now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost
hassle-free way to invest they don't
have bloated sales teams or retail
locations so they can deliver all of
this sophisticated financial advice and
these services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor so at
the very least
go to wealthtrack.com for rushed in and
take their free risk assessment survey
it only takes a couple of minutes and
well front will recommend a personalized
portfolio of investments in other words
they'll tell you exactly where they
put your money so even if you don't use
their service you have a huge leg up and
you have additional information for
making good decisions they use
investment theory to automate good
financial behavior and decisions that
people typically don't make but should
so go to wealthfront compo massage tim
to get your first 15k managed for free
or just to get more details check it out
well front comm forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by vera desk
and I'm actually standing at my own vera
desk right now recording this you've
probably heard of research that shows
how sitting all day is terrible for your
health sitting is the new smoking etc
but standing all day isn't necessarily
the answer for everyone sometimes you
just want to do and that's true for me
as well the middle ground is very desk
very desk height adjustable standing
desk solutions allow you to stand when
you want to and sit when you need to and
as an example I have this set to the
lower position this is a large model and
it took me clickety clack two seconds to
raise this thing up and it feels like
has hydraulics effectively because I
didn't have to use any muscle to do it
vera desk converts your existing desk
for instance if you want to get a
tabletop version which you can put on
which is very very cool or cubical into
a sit stand workstation and allows you
to raise your desk from a seated to
standing position in just seconds ships
fully assembled there is no allen
wrenches screwdrivers required pull it
out of the box put it on your desk in
the case this particular model no
installation or fast name required there
a buncha different options the models
start at just 175 dollars so check out
dere desks comm to see what model might
be the right fit for you and my
assistant now has one I have one we've
really really been very happy with it so
if you're not sure if it's right for you
that's fine they have a 30-day risk free
guarantee which once you try it in your
own home or office and if you decide
it's still not for you you want to get
rid of it they arranged to pick it up no
hassle so check it out bare odesk.com
let the VA RI desk dot-com
you
[Applause]